hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba jonald
we are gonna watch today a video from a
channel called real-life lore this
request comes from a man named Jay and
Valente see at our patreon we kind of
have like a second channel going over
their TV show reactions for many of
shows with love for you guys check that
out as well as fun weekly q and A's I
claim they're fun I don't know what
everyone else thinks but they're still
pledged but one of our reward tiers is
whatever video your question must
definitely do
odds are gonna be a reaction rares the
day they asked for a discussion video
even though we always this custom today
is how the universe is way bigger than
you think it's J n my friend my man who
constantly vanishes and then comes back
with a monologue and the strangest of
vocabulary I'm happy to cover this for
you man you have been a longtime
supporter for us I think even around our
patreon since like day one dude and you
rarely ever ask for anything rarely
asked for anything you're always so
sweet and cynical about other things but
sweet about us and that's why I love you
dude you might not get along with some
parts of the world but you get along
with us and that's what counts in my
heart as long as you like me or okay
that's why I'm friends with all
Republicans I thought I had a joke to go
there there's no joke here
Republicans are okay in my book hey you
know it's good to be inclusive and
tolerant of people who might not think
the way they do you think remember that
Disney star who brought a gun to the
airport
it's easy to forget that that kind of
stuff
you know I hope this video doesn't hurt
my head oh yeah this would be even more
than the history of the entire room this
is a real-life lore video made possible
by Squarespace you know squares bass
beautiful website from Squarespace okay
this is Earth yeah you live here on this
planet somewhere and everything that
you've ever known is located the entire
let's start by zooming out to where we
can see how that here's your cosmic
neighbor the moon you may think that the
moon is very close to Earth since it
dominates our night skies but in reality
the moon isn't this close to our planet
it's actually about this far away Wow
whoa 1400 kilometers away from me right
now on average on a flight away the
entire Earth's in between this dish ah
let's go
somehow we're able to drive a car at a
constant 100 km/h speed it would take
you about 160 days to drive the entire
house despite we could drive to the moon
system and road trip well humans have
actually set foot here representing the
farthest away that any Fraggle Eggman
has ever been away from the earth and it
wasn't for a dancer Titus diffuseness
this is what the earth would look like
from there if you were standing there
with them and if you wanted to
communicate with somebody back at home
it would take a message about two and a
half seconds to travel between you and
them since that's how fast the speed of
light can travel at Wow this is a photo
that was taken on Mars and that tiny dot
that you see there is Earth as seen from
the Martian surface Wow on average Mars
is an incredible 225 million kilometers
away from Earth well she can be - 101
million kilometres which means that
whenever humanity finally gets around to
landing a human on the planet fat Dame's
potatoes who landed on the moon were Wow
Heimdall a for sending a message from
Mars back to earth isn't just two and a
half seconds it's actually more like 20
minutes each direction which would
render instant communication in the
event of an emergency in Mexico be hard
to have a text argument with that object
from Earth it is currently located 138 8
yous from the earth a new meaning
astronaut morally as is the distance
between the Earth and the Sun our cache
means that Voyager 1 is 138 times
further away from us than the
is that some path Wow Voyager 1 turned
its camera around and took this boat
aground it may not look like much at
first but in my opinion this is the
greatest single photograph ever taken in
all of human history why this tiny
haired blue dot is earth and I don't
think that anybody has ever said
something as amazing about this as Carl
Sagan when he said if you look at it you
see a dot that's here that's home that's
us on it everyone you ever heard of
every human being who ever lived
lived out their lives the aggregate of
all our joys and sufferings that I was
rather confident religions ideologies
and economic doctrines every hunter in
every for just living in a sci-fi movie
powered bag of marbles every King and
enemy eyes every young couple in love
every hopeful child every mother and
every father every inventor and Explorer
every teacher of morals every corrupt
politician every superstar every Supreme
Leader every saint and sinner in the
history of our species lived there
Voyager 1 is clearly traveling at 17
kilometers every single second but even
at that speed it won't break out of the
reach of our solar system for another
thirty thousand years catch up once we
go beyond the solar system we arrive in
our interstellar neighborhood here we
shift to the Lightyear unit of
measurement which is the distance that
light travels in a full earthier or
about 9.46 1 trillion kilometers the
star of Proxima Centauri here is the
closest other star to us other than our
Sun but it's still 4.24 light-years away
from us to put that into perspective if
it was heading in the right direction it
would still take Voyager 1 over 70,000
years to reach it another
drove your car at 100 kilometres an hour
like in our previous example to the moon
it would take over six times longer than
the entire age of the universe Wow and
it wouldn't even wildly not described
then we zoom out even further we can see
the entire Milky Way galaxy inside of
which earth is located right here this
yellow dot is the farthest extent of
humanity's radio broadcasts throughout
history which means that any possible
aliens who live outside of this range
are totally unaware of humanity's
presence and complete silence outside of
this yellow dot as far as we are
currently aware they're missing out your
Galaxy spins a great way yeah we got
there are over 100 billion stars and
over 100 billion planets in our galaxy
but you have never seen the full glory
of the galaxy at night because 99% of
the stars that you can see with the
naked eye are limited to the small tiny
region right here
but even this massive galaxy is nothing
compared to the rest of what's out to
there zooming out even further and we
arrived at the local group of galaxies
back here at which the local group here
is just a tiny segment of there are at
least 100 other groups of galaxies just
like our own local group inside of here
and the distance from one site to the
other is a mind-numbing 110 million
light-years but even the math by ear
there's a cluster is nothing but a super
cluster an enormous structure that is
home to our galaxy as well as 100,000
other galaxies the distance from one
side to the other is 520 million
light-years but from the distance light
travels in earthier to the end
observable universe and see that even
the Titanic Laniakea supercluster is
just a tiny and insignificant part of
everything we don't matter and that we
know of it is home to at least two
trillion different and individual
galaxies which together contain more
stars than there are grains of sand on
the entire earth the distance for Earth
to any side of the observable universe
is forty-six point five billion
light-years which the entire width is 93
billion light years across what's
perhaps even more interesting however is
what actually lies beyond the observable
universe one point that the observable
universe is all that we can currently
see in its entire life quality of the
source of the universe inside of it is
vastly larger and more fantastic than we
can possibly ever imagine we simply
don't know what else is out there
because the light from these incredibly
distant places has not yet had enough
time in the universe's history to reach
us yet back on earth and the light from
some places may never reach us at all
because some parts of space very far
away from scenario-based at all of wait
lights faster than the speed of light
that means that the laser balls will
never in an observable buzzer vault the
[Music]
university is eternal and exists forever
there will still be an unknown number of
places in the UAE's Bay may ever know
about or ever see so it is very likely
that as unbelievably enormous as it
seems the observable universe is just a
tiny slice of what we can currently see
of the entire universe according to the
theory of cosmic inflation that was
proposed by dr. Alan Guth if it is
assumed that cosmic inflation began at
10 to the negative thirty seventh of a
second right or the Big Bang the
assumption that the size of the universe
before inflation began was equal to its
age times the speed of light then this
would seem to suggest that at the
present day the entire outer verse is
150 SEC's Tilian times larger than the
observable universe we got the second
just a moment this would be similar to
you thinking that the entire observable
universe everything that you could see
was the size of a light bulb but then
realizing that in reality the entire
universe is larger than the former
planet of Pluto imagine a bulb in the
center of Pluto but we inside the light
bulb we're totally unaware that Pluto
existed outside of it and that's a
similar situation to this we are all so
unbelievable small but you shouldn't
worry because all that means is that
there is so much left up there for us to
discover together maybe an optimistic
whatever new discovery it was made
possible no story house heaven above the
observable basis very guy where space is
great there's weather you stay away from
this video discourse me oh yeah yeah one
thing that's not that many light-years
away is a great website we should do a
livestream where we use this code in a
web say if you like it's not apply it's
not it's mean plugs there might be
applicable thank you for making it it's
great
this video is like a year old right what
if we've discovered more universe since
it dropped yeah where's the updated one
why go to the Griffith Observatory you
could just watch this video yeah really
close you know I love about these kinds
of videos or even going to the Griffith
is how insignificant our lives are yes
we don't matter what we do here all
matter will echo all the way across the
observable of the observe all be
universe I'm saying like all 93
what we do doesn't matter most every
week does it's important that we exists
it's important that earth exists it's
important to us that we exist but what
we do in earth you know
like economy politics all these things
oh yeah do really but this is why we
need a space force man we may even have
a space force yeah I don't know it's
outside of the observable space just we
need a space force to get cracking all
the way man all we know is what's inside
observable space we won't have enough
lifetime to travel that distance but we
should be prepared just in case
trillions of years ago there's a threat
I feel like going into space would be
the most boring I think like the first
day or so the most fascinating time of
your life I is he gonna be like nothing
can talk the level of fascination
they're going to see give it a week this
is the most boring time all I'm doing is
watching Netflix on the Hamm ship going
to space the experience does seem like
picking the greatest destination
vacation and and being confined to a
small hotel but I can't leave my room is
special because so few people have done
this I can see yes everything we know
back home and yet I'm just in this
little can with the same for people like
after a while I would probably be like
guys I'm gonna go out on to the outside
of the spaceship because I'm bored I
would get so bored it's like imagine
you're on a road trip for like like a
month yeah that doesn't stop
yeah some kind of interesting thing
happening around me I you know nothing
needs fixed out maybe that's why people
in space movies are always willing to go
outside the ship and like fixes
dangerous Anil advises feels super dope
if I die this way at least I died do
with some without encountering
life-forms or looking at stars and [ __ ]
that's up forever way you're sitting
there making sure that all the machines
on your spacecraft are functioning
normally and all your vital signs are
good and you know maybe doing a little
research but otherwise you're just
trying to kind of make it like it was
back home if you do a drone shot over
Los Angeles it's beautiful you watch a
time-lapse video of Los Angeles from
day-to-night it's beautiful you sit in
traffic for one hour this is the most
boring time ever yeah it's a totally
different experience too good to do and
to be confined and have a limited
perspective on what you're looking at I
will say though that there's probably no
life on these other planets because the
Bible doesn't talk about it yeah like if
God knows all like he would have
mentioned something he would have
mentioned it that book would have said
it he should have taken time out to be
like guys even though you're never gonna
see this holy [ __ ] so the other stuff
I've made okay it's not the image of me
like you guys are but yeah yeah holy
[ __ ] bad those are a lot of failed
experiments lose your [ __ ] if you could
see some of my other words these planets
the dinosaurs are extinct I just moved
down just like believe so this behind
just make it was like I intended these
to be much smaller we do we make jokes
because we are insignificant we're not
also that great at math I'm like what
when he's doing the math of inflation
size before equals age times speed of
light that's how I usually calculate my
YouTube earnings yeah seven cents all
right
never watched have yeah whenever humans
are popping off and thinking we're a
little too big for our britches I like
to remember that you know this little
dot from across the room were just
another one of these dots immediately
can you imagine we look this video did
for me it made me realize going to the
moon probably wouldn't be that scary it
relatively speaking like I would
actually not be an entirely opposed to
going to the moon whereas before the
idea of space travel just sounds
somewhat terrifying yeah but if I Drive
my car 62 less than happier when you put
it in that person how long does it take
for a spaceship to get there I'm not
talking about like a NASA spaceship time
like Enterprise takes 62 miles per hour
and apply it by like five six so it
takes some time to get there it'll take
a minute but less of a minute that it
would so we got to start working on if
we're gonna make the space force Trump
dude we gotta have a space highway
highway movement space in first
structure is what we need Oh got it and
if our president right now is you know
if he made his wealth off of real estate
you can start building hotels on the way
to the moon like I need like a golden
skyscraper on the moon you know how good
we're doing the biggest these galaxies
expanding everyone's expanding such an
alarming rate if I was a space for
selling real estate yeah yeah he's
somebody to protect all of his buildings
I'm sorry to all the people who think
it's not okay to make jokes about Trump
cuz he's our president and we live in a
dictator like Tommy this country so
don't make fun of the President
oh yeah
you know let's say things that are
against God in those comments yeah free
speech doesn't exist you can insult
everyone and anyone all he wants but
until you disagree with me and at that
point we don't do this the way he broke
down that photo when he was saying this
is the greatest photo I've ever seen
yeah in human history I love the way he
did that word he's going through earth
and what we do this is the dot or just a
dot in this world it's like all the
things that we think are important are
they any time I go to the Griffith night
watchman they're awesome and shows I'm
like this is what I do really relative
at all is is me having an apartment in
surviving zoom out across the galaxy you
start to realize like oh all this [ __ ]
that we're so concerned with down here
like Billings if none of it is the
natural order of things
no edge of stuff that we on Club earth
agreed to if there's one thing I could
barely I know by the time I'm I'm dead
you'll be dead if you're dead I'll be
dead long before I'm dead I was doing
something cool at the time of passing
the one thing I would like to witness if
there's one hope which seemed so
unlikely to discover life on another
planet not me personally but yet
Internet report about it you know that's
the only thing I want out of anything
from the universe is to go yeah and also
to be in the space space force this
video reintroduce the idea to me of just
how limited our reach is in terms of how
much we can see and how much we can get
to in however vast data versus
okay and so now you start to think like
yeah you know probably just a stone's
throw across the universe there's
probably another cluster of galaxies
this is way too far away for us to
really get a good look at and there's
probably a whole bunch of stuff out
there that we have no idea about because
he said like that our furthest our radio
signals have ever reached is that you
know such-and-such a point what if we
just need to get a little further I'm
really fascinated but
of mine said it takes to be an astronaut
I met a guy who was he was one of the
top 100 he didn't ultimately go through
the time I met him he was on the top 100
candidates for that special mission to
Mars movie he was a marketing and he
lost city property
oh not the real one yeah he said the
main tests were actually a psychological
test cos mainly a psych game of you're
having space forever and you're coming
back oh yeah specially with Mars being
like a 20-minute wait to get any kind of
work back and forth because imagine that
tax argument man what though I did not
say that to cool yourself and they take
like 20 minutes to get it and they take
like 20 minutes composing their message
yeah you take that one check here for
got it go for my [ __ ] what are you gonna
say what do you what are you gonna say
oh gosh guys well this is a really
informative video yeah
I hope our talk was just as yeah man you
guys can subscribe to the real life Lord
thanks for making this awesome video or
your old Apple will stand the test of
our times happy birthday and you can
check us out on patreon we've got TV
show reactions week 2 q and A's and also
subscribe for the real rejects and click
that notification about much love to God